[Musique]
elle est belle c'est moi j'ai reçus pour
mes sept ans et quelques jours c'était
juste après le réveillon de noël 1979 à
bruxelles là où je vis là où je vais à
l'école et j'ai une passion
ces petites voitures dans ma chambre
grenier j'ai tout un baril de poudre à
lessiver rempli de petites voitures
il n'attend qu'une chose c'est le jour
où j'aurai 18 ans je pourrai enfin
conduire une vraie grande voiture en
plus à ce moment là on sera tout près de
l'an 2000 je sais pas si vous avez
entendu et pour l'an 2000
toutes les voitures seront capables de
voler si si non ils ont dit à la télé ça
doit ça doit être vrai alors forcément
des voitures qui roulent mais en plus ce
qui vole ça me passionne encore plus et
donc c'est décidé je vais consacrer ma
vie en tout cas ma carrière mes études
aux voitures et quelques années plus
tard en 1999 toujours à bruxelles
je rentre chez un grand est fier
constructeurs automobiles avec une
étoile d'ailleurs qui tourne au dessus
du bâtiment
en 1999 il reste forcément un an avant
l'an 2000
visiblement les voitures sont toujours
pas capables de voler enfin bon quelques
années plus tard début des années 2000
moindrot c'est la crise des 'subprimes'
tous les secteurs économiques sont
touchés et l'automobile ne fait
malheureusement pas exception à la règle
alors je vois beaucoup de mes collègues
se faire licencier remercier d'autres
dont le contrat n'est tout simplement
pas renouvelé moi là dedans mon métier
consiste à pousser convaincre des
concessionnaires des garagistes a
commandé des centaines de voitures
qu'ils doivent financer qui doivent
stocker sur des parkings qui croule à
n'en plus finir dans la tente de clients
qui ne viennent pas puisque c'est la
crise en plus
le secteur automobile commence à avoir
mauvaise presse bouchon pollution aux
particules fines réchauffement
planétaire
tout ça n'est pas très très fun et je
pense que je pense j'ai définitivement
mon rêve de petit garçon et ses voitures
volantes en 2010 9 g j'ai quitté le
monde des importateurs pour voler de mes
propres ailes je donne des formations
d'un consultant je n'ai conférence j'ai
même écrit un livre sur l'avenir de la
mobilité toutes ses conséquences
largement bénéfique et c'est à ce moment
là dans cette année là dans cette
année-ci que débarque une révolution
encore plus disruptif que tout ce que
vous avez connu depuis 20 ans une
révolution qui va changer toutes vos
vies à tous sans exception vie privée
vie professionnelle de vous mais
également de vos parents de vos enfants
de vos voisins de vos collègues de
bureau
et cette révolution ne s'appelle pas
voitures volantes les voitures autonomes
des véhicules tout à fait capable
d'aller d'un point a à un point b
parfois distants de plusieurs milliers
de kilomètres sans aucune forme
d'intervention à bord ni depuis
l'intérieur ni même depuis l'extérieur
du véhicule et au delà de simplement
rouler tout seul au niveau organisation
elles vont complètement changer notre
manière de vivre et vont même nous
transformer nous mêmes à tel point que
quelques années plus tard en ce matin du
19 janvier 2039
je suis devenu un véritable assister ça
commence le matin déjà par mon fidèle
petit robot domestique digne héritier du
petit r2d2 de ma jeunesse et qui non
content de me réveiller le matin déjà
passé toute la nuit à m'écouter am
analyse et analyser mon sommeil le matin
pendant je prends ma douche une de ses
rares activités que je fasse encore seul
il me raconte mes rêves les interprètes
et en même temps il me racontant pas les
messages les mails que j'ai reçus
pendant la nuit mais également toutes
les réponses personnalisées qui s'est
permis d'envoyer de lui-même il a déjà
le bon goût de m'en informer
et en même temps il a commandé en
cuisine mon petit déjeuner sur base
d'aliments qui me sont livrés tous les
matins par un autre petit robot
domestique puisque il ya bien longtemps
que je ne sais plus mais course moi-même
et certainement pas pour des choses
si passionnante que de la salade ou des
lardons pendant je termine ma douche il
est déjà occupé à préparer mon agenda de
la semaine il s'arrête jamais il dort
jamais il gesticule dans tous les sens
je vais même surnommé sarkozy pour vous
dire en en l'hommage de enfin je crois
que vous avez saisi le principe ce matin
de janvier 2039 j'ai un rendez vous à
berlin
un rendez vous professionnel si entre
temps j'ai 65 ans il me reste encore une
bonne quinzaine d'années derrière devant
moi puisque récemment une dernière loi
travail vient de placer l'âge de la
pension à 81 ans
donc si ça aussi le ne rigolez pas trop
vite ou bien
mais bon au moins ce voyage vers berlin
je vais le faire en parfait confort
puisque un show l'autonome vient me
chercher à la maison et m'amène jusqu'à
la gare du midi à bruxelles ou un ipod
loupé mon mènera à peu près en 45
minutes jusqu'à berlin ma destination
puisque l' hyper loue pas ce train sur
champ magnétique
inauguré en 2019 entre dubai abu dhabi
si vous souvenez c'était il ya vingt ans
voyage à peu près à 1200 km heure donc
ça devrait aller assez vite et une fois
à destination d'ailleurs j'ai un drone
autonome un volet kopter qui va
m'emmener jusque sur le toit du bâtiment
où a lieu la réunion et puis ma réunion
se passe très bien d'ailleurs merci pour
moi mais revenons en 2019 car si ma vie
est la vôtre sur tout va changer
et bien au delà des quelques exemples
que je viens de citer ici ce changement
a commencé en 2019
car c'est à partir de l'année 2010 9 que
petit à petit et puis depuis manière
plus massive des voitures autonomes vont
commencer à se répandre sur toutes les
routes de la planète et du coup petit à
petit il redevient également agréable de
rouler en voiture pour plein de raisons
déjà parce que les bouchons sont
l'histoire ancienne les bouchons causés
à 50% par des voitures en train de
chercher à se garer ont disparu tout
simplement parce que les voitures
autonomes n'ont pas besoin de parking en
tout cas pas dans les centres villes ce
dont elles ont besoin
c'est des zones de dépose rapide pour
vous prendre ou déposer reprendre
quelqu'un lorsqu'elles sont en libre
partage et si vous en avez une à vous
est tout à fait capable de vous conduire
le matin de conduire les enfants qu'on
vire madame déposé un colis se charger
dans le coffre en commission puis encore
aller jouer les taxis pour vous à
l'aéroport tout près histoire de vous
ramener un petit peu d'argent en fin de
journée nous forme dubé risation avant
de vous ramener vous-même au bercail en
fin de journée pour plein de raisons
elle déjoue les bouchons parce qu'elles
sont capables de les anticiper
ne pas aller se mettre dedans mais
également les communiquer leurs petites
soeurs qui sont derrière de sorte que le
trafic reste toujours parfaitement
fluide
et puis pour plein de raisons elles
n'émettent plus lisse et o2 ni
particules fines ni hainaut x ni autres
polluants tout simplement parce qu'elles
sont devenues quasi exclusivement
électrique et là aussi les choses ont
très fort et très vite changer tous les
constructeurs s'y sont mis mais
également les producteurs de batteries
des batteries réparera désormais
recyclables qui contiennent plus de
carbone que les matériaux rares pour
lesquels ils étaient décriée qui ont des
temps de recharge de quelques minutes
pour des autonomies de centaines de
kilomètres elles sont capables
puisqu'elles sont autonomes d'aller
surchargé d'elle-même sur des bornes à
induction qui existent déjà aujourd'hui
est de se recharger avec de l'énergie
électrique essentiellement verte est
essentiellement d'origine solaire
d'ailleurs résultat des centaines de
millions de panneaux photovoltaïques qui
année après année ont été produits ont
été commercialisés de sorte que
l'énergie solaire est forcément
écologique mais également la plus
économique et beaucoup d'entre vous et
d'entre nous d'ailleurs se déplacent de
manière tout à fait gratuite
est ce qu'ils produisent eux mêmes leur
électricité et puis intelligence
artificielle est passée par là aussi est
désormais tous ses moyens de transport
coexistent co animent ensemble train
tram voitures trottinette vélo voitures
autonomes sont autant de maillons relié
dans une seule et même chaîne la bloque
chaîne de la mobilité mais que l'on
appelle masse mobility à ce service se
déplaçait dans les années 2030 ne sait
plus avec une voiture ou un vélo n'avait
que cet ensemble de véhicules à nos
dispositions
relier interconnecté travaillant
ensemble pour les utiliser rien de plus
simple une seule ap
dans lequel vous les voyez tous
pouvaient tous les cartographier les
utiliser via un seul outil un seul
opérateur et une seule facture à la fin
du mois un petit peu comme ce que nous
connaissons déjà en matière de
téléphonie
alors imaginez un monde dans lequel nous
passons plus des milliers d'heures
bêtement derrière un volant dans les
bouchons du temps de qualité nous allons
pouvoir récupérer pour activités bien
plus intéressantes comme se reposer déjà
boire manger dormir lire ses mails
travailler surfer sur internet
faire des câlins aussi tant qu'à faire
et tout ça dans un parfait confort et en
parfaite sécurité
alors imaginez l'impact sur notre stress
notre qualité de vie
l'impact sur l'environnement l'impact
sur l'aménagement du territoire car
désormais il redevient aussi possible
d'aller vivre dans les campagnes avec
toute la qualité de la vie au grand air
sans les désagréments d'être loin de
tout mais vivent dans les villes
redevient également agréable dans des
centres villes les agglomérations
débarrasser tous ces véhicules
klaxonnant polluants e occupant un
espace au sol tout à fait inutile
imaginez l'impact sur la qualité de la
vie mais une conséquence bien plus
importante aussi c'est sur la vie
elle-même
depuis je m'intéresse aux voitures
autonomes j'ai réalisé à quel point tous
les acteurs de cette mobilité du futur
partagé un point commun avait fait qu'il
soit développeurs testore ingénieurs
simples amateurs de cette mobilité du
futur
ils partageaient tous comme point commun
le drame d'avoir vécu la perte d'un être
cher dans un bête accident de la route
car un accident de la route sera
toujours bête ou si bête que ses
conséquences
elle par contre sont dramatiques et
plutôt que de voir ça comme une fatalité
eux avaient décidé d'agir décidé qu'ils
n'étaient plus acceptables qu'on 21e
siècle dans une année comme 2018 il est
encore chaque année 60 millions
d'accidents sur les routes
c'était l'équivalent de la population de
l'italie et que 60 millions génère
d'ailleurs un million trois cent
cinquante mille morts chaque année
l'équivalent de la population de l'île
de chypre comme si chypre couler chaque
année avec tous ses habitants à bord
hallucinant par jour cela représente
l'équivalent de dix boeing 737 se crashe
ont simultanément la mortalité routière
c'est ça et par rapport à ça lorsque
tous les véhicules du montout le parc
roulant mondiale sera devenue autonome
ça prendra dix vingt ou trente ans et
satan dépendra beaucoup de nous
d'ailleurs la mortalité sera éradiquée
est ce qui permet de l'affirmer alors
que vous allez me dire mais ne roule pas
encore si nous les utilisons pas encore
mais toutes ensemble elles ont déjà
dépassé les 100 millions de kilomètres
de tests réels
sur toutes les routes de la planète 2500
fois le tour de la terre cinq milliards
de kilomètres virtuel avait quasi aucune
accidentalité alors qu'elles sont encore
en phase test pour l'instant alors
imaginez un monde assez proche et
espérons le dans lequel nous devons plus
nous inquiéter chaque fois qu'un de nos
proches monde à bord d'un véhicule pour
aller au boulot partir en vacances ou
pour entrer de boîte de nuit et samedi
soir imbibé de fête et d'alcool plutôt
que d'imaginer de se dire bah on verra
bien c'est la technologie pouvons déjà
choisir accepter cette technologie ou la
refuser lasnier l'adénine parce que
finalement le déni est un choix
démocratique est d'ailleurs l'histoire
industrielle est très riche d'exemples
d'accidents et commerciaux n'est liée au
déni le plus connu est probablement
kodak qui était ultra leader du marché
de la photo et qui n'a tout simplement
pas cru dans l'avenir de la photo
digitale exemple est devenue celle fr ça
donnez lui une expression vous
connaissez peut-être eu berries et vous
si vous ne voulez pas vous faire kodak
et nokia autre exemple ultra leader du
marché de la téléphonie
jusqu'au début des années 2010 et qui
n'a pas cru dans l'avenir du smartphone
et doute les capacités que ça donnait
bien au delà de simplement téléphoner et
envoyer des messages et puis lorsqu'on
parle de voiture l'automobile a
également son exemple et pour vous en
convaincre il suffit de visiter le musée
de mercedes à stuttgart la première
chose que vous verrez dans son musée de
voitures c'est pas une voiture c'est un
cheval un cheval empaillé et ce qui
retient l'attention figure au pied du
cheval en question une citation du
kaiser de l'époque guillaume 2 qui fin
du 19e siècle disait je crois dans
l'avenir du cheval
la voiture ne sera qu'un phénomène de
mode et n'a aucun avenir
alors avec un siècle de recul dont nous
disposons cette citation peuvent nous
faire sourire mais si on la remet par
contre dans son contexte
on peut imaginer que ses pensées étaient
partagés par l'intégralité de la
population de l'époque l'être humain
jusque là avait passé des millénaires à
vivre
avec le cheval à côté du cheval à se
développer grâce au cheval ne dit on pas
cheval vapeur et il était complètement
impensable inimaginable qu'en moins
d'une décennie le cheval soit remplacé
parce que jacquouille la fripouille
appelez-la chariot du diable la première
fois qu'ils envient une et bien en 2019
nous sommes à ce même moment à ce même
point de bascule vers une nouvelle
mobilité que vous nous amenez les
voiture autonome et voitures autonomes
seront à la voiture ce que la voiture a
été au cheval et nous aussi nous pouvons
le nier le dénigrer est laïque et
commenter sur sur internet sur tous les
réseaux sociaux chaque fois qu'il aura
un accident grave ou pas impliquant une
voiture autonome car ça arrivera
évidemment nié dénigrer c'est exactement
ce qui s'est passé le 18 mars 2018 ya
tout juste un an
et ce jour-là eu lieu le premier
accident mortel impliquant une voiture
autonome et cet accident bien que
évidemment dramatique à rats morts sur
les routes sera toujours un mort de trop
a été relayée par tous les réseaux
sociaux par tous les sites internet par
tous les médias radio télé aurait
probablement vu les images au journal
télévisé parce que ça fait la une de
tous les journaux de cette voiture dont
je ne citerai pas la marque géré par
hubert à tel point que le gestionnaire
über à du jour au lendemain dû arrêter
tous ses essais et que l'état d'arizona
où avec lui l'accident a également
interdit par décret du jour en lendemain
les essais de voitures autonomes sur son
territoire paradoxalement dans la même
journée c'est pas un mort les 3500
personnes qui sont décédées sur toutes
les routes de la planète et ces morts-là
n'ont pas généré la moindre ligne dans
la presse internationale
preuve du caractère éminemment
psychologique et sociologique de ces
voitures autonomes
pourtant au départ uniquement
technologies alors plutôt que de nier
dénigrer nous pouvons également agir et
agir ça commence par s'y intéresser avec
un oeil objectif lire youtube est monté
à bord de certains de ses shows
l'autonome y compris en france
keith qui sillonnent déjà comme les
petits navires des petits minibus qui
sont déjà dans les centres villes dans
certains centres urbains dans certains
aéroports
certains zoning commerciaux industrie
les parcs d'attractions un petit peu
partout montez à bord s'y acclimater et
petit à petit accepter l'idée que la
machine puisse être meilleur que nous
dans la réalisation de certaines tâches
comme de conduire une voiture et au plus
vite
nous accepterons ses plus grandes
facultés cognitives de la machine par
rapport à l'être humain et qui ne
verront pas comme un ennemi de notre
propre mobilité humaine ou plus vite
alors elles pourront se répandre sur
leur route en amenant avec elle toutes
leurs plus values en matière de confort
de qualité de vie mais surtout de lutte
contre cette inacceptable millions trois
cent cinquante mille morts annuels
inutile inacceptable et injuste pour
terminer je voudrais juste vous inviter
à mon réveillon de noël 2059 jusqu'à
entre temps je suis arrière grand père
notamment d'un petit garçon de 7 ans il
ya quelques minutes mon arrière petit
fils a redescendu du grenier un baril de
poudre à lessiver presque centenaire
entre temps et contenant toute ma
collection précieuse des petites
voitures de mon enfance il m'en donne
une et me demande ça marche comment
alors moi tout fier est vraiment ce que
ça pour moins je connais j'explique ça
marche pas que ça fonctionne le rôle du
conducteur
et pendant que je l'exploit qu'il s'en
va jouer à autre chose et que
visiblement le sujet ne l'intéresse pas
plus que ça pas plus que finalement
lorsque mon propre grand père me parlait
de locomotive à vapeur et ce petit
garçon me laisse méditer sur cet objet
du passé je me sens moi-même un petit
peu du passé
peut-être complètement dépassé
peu importe finalement si les voitures
sont volante ou pas et si le monde dans
lequel mon arrière petit fils va grandir
ce monde est loin d'être parfait au
moins je sais que je ne devrais pas
m'inquiéter à l'idée que lui ou ses
propres enfants puissent être un jour la
victime d'un bête accident la route
merci
[Applaudissements]